(adventurous music)
- [Will] I'm throwing
myself into the unknown.
- I almost guarantee
you're going to survive.
- Am I?
(Will laughing)
(adventurous music continues)
- [Will] There's a new breed of explorers
taking me to the ends of the earth
to discover hidden worlds.
- Ooh!
- That sit beyond our senses.
(wind blowing)
- How's that feeling?
- Scary as hell. You
know exactly how it feel.
(Dwayne laughing)
(high intensity music)
- Once you decode the mysteries,
you can find crucial information
about the world around us.
- Ready when you are.
We're trying to see the invisible.
- Wow.
So I could be one of the
first people to ever see this.
[Diva and Will] - What!
- Inside this sub at 3000 feet.
- And the only thing protecting you
is about six inches of plastic.
- We down here, y'all. We down here.
(Diva laughing)
(music intensifies)
- [Will] You gotta be kidding me.
- That was beautiful.
- Wow.
- Anything dangling?
- Just you.
I'm not going to need
to do that two times.
- No?
(Will laughing)
- That looks crazy.
There's a different planet down there.
How did I not know that
this was in the world?
(music intensifies)
Wow. I'm so putting this in a movie.
(Diva laughing)
I am so putting this in a movie.